- It ain't but three
things I ain't never seen,
a UFO, a faithful hole
and a pimp slip to pussy.
- [Interviewer] All right.
What is your name?
- [Diamond] Diamond D.
- [Interviewer] Diamond D.
- [Interviewer] Diamond
D where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in LA.
- [Interviewer] South central?
- South central LA.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
Both your parents when you were young.
- Childhood, no, I was
raised up in a single home
with just my mom
and we had some rough
days, you know what I mean?
And some hungry days,
but once I found out about
how to get some money,
then I went out on my own at 13.
And I start started off just by
running around the
neighborhood, Hollywood,
Inglewood.
I started hanging around the pimps
and the players
because they was the
one getting the money.
And they was the one
that had all the girls.
And I liked the girls,
you know what I mean?
So I started hanging with them
and they started schooling me
and putting me in the
circle with the pimps,
the real pimps and players.
So I just took to that
and I started liking the game.
You know what I'm saying?
I started liking the game
and the money was fast
and the game was good.
It was good to me, you know.
I dropped out of school.
So I didn't have no education.
- [Interviewer] How far did you go?
- I think I went to the seventh grade.
Dropped out of school
and I was afraid to breaking houses
or rob or do anything else.
So the next best thing
that I knew how to do was manipulate.
Manipulate the females into
doing what they needed to do
in order to put money in my pocket for,
so I could do what I needed to do.
And from that point,
as I started to mature
and grow up,
it all came together like a puzzle.
Once I had control over their mind,
everything fell in place.
- [Interviewer] Is that the key of the...
Prostitute relationship is controlling.
- Control, control.
It's not a bad thing,
control and management basically.
- [Interviewer] But yoh if you
watching enough of my videos
you see how girls, the women
are things that are just
like, it's makes you question.
Like, why would you give
away all your money?
Work all night, do dangerous things.
- Because it's a business.
- [Interviewer] All your money
who's sitting back watching.
- It's a business, it's a business.
It's one of the oldest
professions around prostitution.
- [Interviewer] But the girl
gives you all the money.
- All the money.
- [Interviewer] And what
does she get out of it?
- Whatever she wants, I manage it.
I make sure she got a roof.
I make sure she eat.
I make sure she got nice clothing
and whatever else she may want.
In the event that she may
have a drug addiction,
I make sure she has that, all that.
Opposed to her getting the money
and just going out there giving it away
and become homeless,
living on the streets.
A Renegade, what we call renegade.
Renegade hoes that every
mother fucker is after
to try to get.
Take their money, rob
them, all that, protection.
- [Interviewer] So the
renegades get hassled
because they're free?
- Exactly. So protection is also...
- [Interviewer] So by being with a pimp
you're kind of safer?
- Exactly because I mean, in that circle,
in the pimp game, they respect that
that's another man's woman
unless she decides to choose another pimp.
- [Interviewer] How easy is it
for a girl to go from one pimp to another?
- I mean, it's not that hard.
I mean, if, cause the game is
kind block in block, you know,
you got to accept to loosing
like you accept to choosing.
- [Interviewer] But does she
have to pay anybody to do that?
- I mean, a choosing fee.
A bitch can't come to me without no money.
If you wanna be on my team,
you gotta have a choosing fee.
And I gotta serve your pimp
or whoever you was with
and let them know this is my hoe now,
now ain't no longer your hoe.
And you gotta accept the
loosing with the choosing.
Simple as that.
- [Interviewer] And how difficult is it
for a girl to get out completely?
Let's say she wants to live a square life.
- Well, they got the gorilla pimps.
They won't let them out.
Then they got to pimps that's not gorilla.
Don't beat up, bro.
I don't put my hands on no female.
That's what I don't do.
But you've got those that will.
You know what I mean?
And more or less they're
frightened to leave
or frightened to choose someone else
or go to another pimp or to
wherever they might wanna go.
However, if you got your game in order,
then they aint going nowhere.
There'll be with, you know.
It's a lot of...
Drama in the pimp game.
It's a game where...
You have to be able to be versatile.
You gotta be versatile.
In order to stay on top.
And keep your hoes in order.
You gotta keep them in order.
You gotta have control
over this, over their mind.
Once you have control,
once you have the mind,
you got everything.
- [Interviewer] And was that
something that came naturally
to you or you learned it?
- Came natural.
- I learned at a young age
that when you sex a hoe,
you're in their world.
But when you get in their
mind, they're in your world.
Feel me?
Yeah when you get in their
mind they're in your world.
But if you sex some,
you're in their world.
- [Interviewer] If you
have sex with then...
- You're in their world.
- [Interviewer] So it's all about control.
- It's all about control.
Not with just this head,
move the other head too.
You gotta have control
over self for number one.
Once you can control self,
you can control everything
in your perimeter.
- [Interviewer] How many girls
will you have in your stable?
- How many had ones?
I've had six at one time.
- [Interviewer] You're still active today?
You're still active today?
- Yeah. That's my number
one hoe right there.
She'd been around a long time.
She'd been around.
She'd been with me for almost 20 years.
- [Interviewer] 20 years?
- 20 years.
- [Interviewer] You gotta
be doing something, right?
- Yeah. She the only one
that's been faithful.
- [Interviewer] He treats you well?
- To a certain extent,
to a certain extent.
Like I told you before it
ain't, but three things
I ain't never seen.
A UFO, a faithful hoe and
a pimp slip to a pussy.
She somewhat faithful.
She'd been with me.
Yeah. But yeah.
So right this day in time, you know, I
I'm doing some other things.
I'm doing some entrepreneurial stuff and
some intervention for the youngsters
you know what I'm saying?
Try to show them another way to go.
You know, because it's a lot of drama.
It's a lot of drama.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] what do
you think most players
don't understand about the pimp game?
What do most players
not understand about it?
- That is a business.
It's a business.
When a John or player thing is just about
leisure or being sex
or whatever, you know?
So they don't understand
that this is a way of life.
Like they go to work and do construction
or what have you.
Go to work too every day?
This is what pays my bills.
This is what I'm able to put on the table.
This is what take care of my hoes.
What I do, management,
you know, it's management.
And like I said, it's a business.
It's not just a game.
It's a business.
- [Interviewer] You ever
been in love before?
- Have I ever been in love?
I mean, I love her.
I ain't never been in love,
but I love her.
- [Interviewer] What's more
important, money or love?
- Money, MOB.
You know what MOB stands for?
- What's MOB?
- Money Over Bitches.
- [Interviewer] You done prison time?
- Yeah. I've been to
prison a couple of times.
- [Interviewer] What for?
- I did white collar shit.
I've been for...
forgery shit like that, federal time.
Have been for manufacturing illegal drugs.
Other than then,
I had no pimp (indistinct)
you knew what they call it white
or what'd they used to
call it white slavery.
Now they call it what human trafficking?
That caries a life sentence.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
the fines are harsh now.
- Yeah. It carries a life sentence.
- [Interviewer] It is much more dangerous
than it used to be.
- Yeah. It is because it's, you know
it's all, the shit that's
going on with the kids.
So you got a lot of pedophiles.
This selling women, selling kids,
you know what I'm saying?
I don't agree to that.
- [Interviewer] And what do
you think of the new breed
of they're basically gang
members that are hustling girls
as their pimp, but
they're not really pimps.
They're just like gang
members that are pimping them.
- A lot of the youngsters now,
they control a hoe with dope.
With substances.
I mean, unless you get a
hoe that really love you,
you don't have to do all that.
it's just all about marking and fucking.
Show and tell, that's
what is true, you know
primarily all about show and tell.
If I can tell you something,
I can show you as well.
You know what I'm saying?
My word is like, God, they
will never return void.
- [Interviewer] Do you
ever have to get physical
with a girl or intimidate
them or use force?
- With a female?
- yeah.
- I mean, I never gotten physical,
but I've had to intimidate them
to a certain point sometime,
throughout my career,
throughout my career.
I've had to intimidate them,
and say some things
that may have put fear in them.
But sometime that's what you had to do.
You had to put fear in them.
Like put fear in God.
Like that's what it's gonna be.
And that's all it is.
It's gonna be like this and that's it.
You know what I mean?
But as far as physically abusing him, no.
No I've never had to do that.
I'm not a gorilla pimp.
I ain't never beat up a woman
because that don't get it.
You know what I'm saying?
That's not what it's all about,
but you got those hoes they like that.
And you got to do (indistinct)
That's what they do.
That's how they keep them.
Fear, fear.
I'm trying to be good and plenty.
I ain't trying to put fear in my hoe.
I'm trying to be good and give up plenty.
You know what I mean?
So, that's just the way it is with me.
That's the school I come from,
the rug that I'm cut from.
- [Interviewer] Are the other
girls in your stable ever,
preying guys for their money,
their jewelry, their wallets.
- Oh yeah have had a few thieves.
- I've had a few.
- [Interviewer] But people understand that
that's part of the game?
- That's part of the game.
But you know what?
They respect that.
A trick have to respect that
when she do it the right way.
I had a hoe that would
take the Rolex's off
of motherfuckers neck,
take his money out of his wallet
and put it back in his
pocket, all in one motion
without him knowing.
And then at the end of the
day, they had to respect that
because that's just the way it was.
And they laugh about it or whatever.
and they date her again,
you know what I mean?
Yeah. So it's been some, you know
I've had some trying times.
And I've had to check some guys about her
by my woman, by my hoes, I
have to check some of them.
Because like I said,
they don't understand it is a business.
It's not just fun and games.
- [Interviewer] There's some
women that are cut out for it
and some that are just not...
- Some are and some not.
Some are cut out to be a hoe,
some are cut out to be housewives.
Me personally, I don't
want nothing but a hoe.
You know what I'm saying?
I respect a hoe because they
the first thing to laid down
and the last thing to get up.
And the chances that they take,
they never know who they might be with.
You feel me?
So I understand all that shit.
You know what I mean?
I never tell them that, but I understand.
And I understand the fear
that they have when they
step out on that blade.
When they step out on that blade,
is fear.
They got fear it, ain't not one hoe
that I've had, that I know,
they didn't have fear
when she hit the blade.
- [Interviewer] Fear of
what the tricks might do?
- Exactly.
- Exactly. She might not show it.
She may not show it,
but I'm gonna encourage her
that I'm gonna be there
for her in the event
that she needs me I'll be there.
- [Interviewer] How would you do that?
Let's say I picked up your young lady here
and I wanted to get crazy
and I had a knife or a
gun or whatever the hell,
how would you know about it?
- Once I give her instructions,
as long as she followed my
instructions, she'll be okay.
- [Interviewer] But how
would she let you know
that there's trouble with me?
- Telephone call or possibly a spotter.
I might have a spotter following her
just to make sure that she all right
- [Interviewer] I've heard some
of the girls will leave their phones on
for the entire...
Session that she has with the guy.
- Yeah of course.
- [Interviewer] So you can hear
everything that's going on.
- Exactly.
There's a time limit.
Once that time limit is up,
then now it's time to go.
Now it's time for me to step to the plate.
- [Interviewer] What's some
of the craziest behavior
you've seen in your years of doing this?
You gotta have a story or two, right?
- I have one girl.
She turned her date and she
was gone longer than usual.
So anytime they're gone longer than usual,
then now I'm in question
about what's going on.
But I know she has a spot
especially if she's dating in a car,
she has a designated
place to date that I know.
Anything other than that,
then she's gonna get out the car.
If the trick can't go there
to the designated spot,
she don't date.
However, she had a date
and she took a little longer than normal.
So I started to patrol the perimeter.
I didn't see the car.
So I hit a corner
and then I seen her coming
up the street, right?
She's in the middle of street
and this dude is following her.
So when she see me she come to me, right?
Now dude took her and
stabbed her in the head.
She's bleeding and shit, right?
So I pulled my pistol.
I said, what's going on?
She gave me the money and shit right?
He tells me, he said look,
he said, "I paid her but
I didn't get my nuts.
"I didn't climb climax, right?"
She said baby he lying.
Because she had a condom in her
mouth and he didn't know it.
And she pulled it out and she said,
here it is right here baby.
Here it is, right here.
And so I didn't go stupid.
You know what I'm saying?
I just kind of told dude to
get on, you got to fuck on.
But he never knew she had
a condom in her mouth.
You know what I mean?
So that was, and then I had
an incident in New York.
One of my girls had got a
merchant Marine for money built
and it went through a
picture window and shit.
It was crazy.
You know what I mean?
She went to jail
but she was able to give me the money belt
before she went to jail.
I went down and bailed her out.
They're fighting and tussling and shit.
But anyway, I was able to go get her out.
- [Interviewer] Do you travel
other states with your girls?
- I've been around.
I've been around this country.
I've been to Albuquerque.
I've been to Chicago,
have been to Florida.
I've been to Utah.
I've been to Arizona.
And worked all our hoes.
Work all those blades.
So I've been around.
- [Interviewer] What do you think the core
of the pimp and prostitute
relationship is?
Does she have like a damaged
or a rough relationship with her father?
And then she finds similar treatment
with the tricks and the pimps.
- Some of the girls don't.
They have broken homes, you know,
where they've been molested or
they feel less than
the rest of the family.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. If you came from
that kind of childhood,
this career with a pimp, with the tricks
that are just using you,
is an adult replacement
for them in my mind.
what do you think of that?
- Sometime we take advantage of that.
We capitalize on that.
I do sometimes, no lie.
I capitalize on that.
- [Interviewer] I think
that's how a female gets
into this career.
- Exactly. You know,
we capitalize on that.
- [Interviewer] A girl with
a great father is not gonna--
- No, those are the kind
of hoes we look for.
- [Interviewer] The broken ones?
- The broken home with the broken ones.
It's what you look for.
Build them back up,
build their self-esteem,
make them feel that there's somebody.
- [Interviewer] Easy to control.
- Easier to control.
You know, easier to control,
especially when you give them
what they parents couldn't give them
or you do for them what
their parents didn't do.
That's what they're looking for.
Everybody's looking for love.
Every hoe is looking for love.
And that's how you got show love.
Show some love.
Sometimes you gotta be stern though.
Sometime you can't show no love.
You gotta show tough love.
You know, you gotta show tough love.
You know what I'm saying?
And the vintage, she come
back without her quarter.
You don't meet your quarter tonight?
You gotta meet your quarter.
If you're supposed to get 500,
you're suppose to get 1000 a night.
You need not come back
until you have a thousand.
- [Interviewer] How
common are drugs a part
of the same for the girls?
- How common are the drugs?
Some of them are, it's very common
but I don't like hoes that use drugs,
because the drugs is all
a mind altering substance.
And I don't need no hoes of
mine to be altered by no drugs.
Something that can't
even talk or something
that's controlling them rather than me.
You feel me?
So I don't like dealing with
hoes with drug addictions.
That's not good
because like I said,
they will control the hoes.
If they get too many of them in them
I'd had hoes run off
behind drugs, you know?
And I did have some hoes did use drugs
and had to let them do what they do.
Be who they are.
You feel me?
Long as I get what I
supposed to get, you know?
Cause I got other hoes
I gotta take care of.
I gotta bills I gotta pay.
I got a lot of I gotta do man.
So it's common. It's common.
Because when they come, to a lot of times
when they come to you, they got issues.
And they already on drugs.
And they trying to medicate they self
with the drugs.
But I'm the doctor.
I'm the doctor.
I'm a Medicate them.
So I don't need you to be on no drugs.
I'm the doctor.
You feel me?
Yeah. So...
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your
years of doing this.
- Say that again?
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your
years of doing this?
- The most important lesson I've learned.
Was how to control a person's mind.
How to control a hoes mind.
That's what's important.
That was the lesson to learn
in order to be successful.
How does control the mind,
first and foremost,
once you can control the mind
the body will follow.
The body is nothing,
it's the mind that I'm after.
I'm not after the body.
That the body gonna
follow the mind, feel me?
- [Interviewer] Did you have kids?
- I got a gang of kids.
- [Interviewer] How many
kids do you think you got?
- About seven, eight.
- [Interviewer] And did you raise them?
- I took care of them.
I took care of them.
I made sure they didn't want for nothing.
- [Interviewer] You have some girls?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How would you feel if one
of your girls was...
- How would I feel?
I'm a pimp.
Ain't no feelings, not in that profession
because like I said,
that's the oldest profession in the world,
one of the oldest.
Prostitution been here since day one.
So I mean, if that's
what she chooses to do,
then that's what she do.
Not because I'm a pimp because
I get mine from her a hoe,
but if that's what she want
to do, that's where she do.
I'm a still respect her and love her.
I mean, hey,
that's just the way it
is with me, you know?
- [Interviewer] Alrighty
D. Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
Thank you so much.
Very interesting.
- [Diamond] Very interesting.
- [Interviewer] Thank you man.
- [Diamond] Tell me this, you're gonna...